ان حضر المنسف فالتاريخ والتراث حكايات
تروى على نار هادئه حبات الجميد هذه
مرتبطه بطبيعه البلاد وثقافه اهلها اما
قطع اللحم فتعنا بتوجيب الضيف يتوسطها
الراس اكراما له كل هذا ماتورثه الاردنيون
عن ابائهم القدماء الذين تناول المنسف قبل
سبعه الاف عامه
[تصفيق]
يتعدى المنسف مضمونه كاكله شعبيه وتراثيه
الى كونه يمثل لغه تواصل مع الضيف والاهل
فهو الحاضر لكافه المناسباتها وحتى نهائي
من سفن هذا الكثير من العادات والتقاليد
سترافق تقديمه وصولا لتناوله
اجتماعيه واخلاقيه ارتبطت بالشهامه والكرم
والمروءه
ويمثل الاردنيه منذ الاف السنين حتى يومنا
هذا همم هذا وتسجيله لائحه التراث العالمي
يؤكد على بقائه للمستقبل
وفيما يعد المنسف ارثا اردنيا يحتاج وقتا
كبيرا لشرح مكوناته التي كانت قديما تتكون
من اللحم واللبن وفتاه الخبز تحاول الصوره
اهم مراحل تحضيره التي تطورت ارزن ترثه
فوقه قطع اللحم ومن ثم كابل اللبن وكتفا
بكتف يقف المدعوون حوله كل ياكل من امامه
ضمن بروتوكولات ارتبطت خاصه بالمنسف ما
يمثله المنسف من قيم واخلاق وتقاليد
يستطيع ان يجمع الاضداد وان يجمع الفرقاء
في مكان واحد وعلى مائده مستديره ارتباطه
بالحياه الاجتماعيه الاردنيه
له علاقه مباشره بالاواصر الاجتماعيه
بحل الخلافات ومن اكله اردنيه الى طبق
يحظى بشعبيه عربيه وحتى عالميه فعاده ما
يستقبل الاردنيون ضيوفهم بقولهم يا مرحبا
بالضيف افلح على الزاد والزاد بالتاكيد لن
يكون الا منسفا يحمل الكثيره من تاريخ اهل
الاردن وهو لسانه حالهم عندما يكون الحديث
عن الكرم
ميزات كثيره ادرجت المنسف على قائمه
التراث الثقافي غير المادي لليونسكو وسط
فرحه اهله وعشاقه
استطاع المنسف بكل جداره ان يكون سفير
المائده الاردنيه الامر الذي يحمل عشاقه
مسؤوليه اكبر يبقى لتحضيره وطبخه وحتى
اكله كيف لا وكل ما تذوقه مني ضيف عاد
ليطلب مني اعداده له مره اخرى وكانه لم
يتذوقه من قبل
الى العربيه اما
[موسيقى]